make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are covering
uh the first issue of sword now um i'm
not really sure what direction this is
all gonna go in and the reality is
there's so much happening in
x or not really even actually swords and
dawn of x already um
this might be one of the stories that we
do where we only really cover it in
volumes right so we'll cover this first
issue and then we won't really cover it
again until we pick up with when until
it concludes with the first arc and then
we'll cover all the rest of it you know
kind of call it like a conclusion or
part two or whatever it is
but i do think it's important to
establish that this is here
because what this is doing is it's
moving the whole idea of krakowa and the
mutant population beyond earth
and focusing more on the stars now the
funny thing about this is that this is
written by al ewing and in recent years
al ewing has kind of become the new dan
admin right those guys who don't know
what that means
for years leading up to like 2006 when i
say years i mean like
decades marvel's whole uh i guess space
escapades their space opera was usually
sort of
hit by different people here and there
but it was never really cohesive right
so you go back and you read the old jim
starlin warlock stories or the old jim
starlin thanos silver surfer stories
then you see a lot of space-faring
escapades there
you had stories involving wendell vaughn
as quasar you had stories
involving uh captain marvel himself
right marvello the cree
but you didn't really have any kind of
cohesiveness there you had story arcs
right so you had like
infinity war or infinity gauntlet or the
infinity crusade or something like that
but in 2006 dan
admit basically took the entirety of
everything going on in space and marvel
and consolidated all of it down into a
story called
annihilation an annihilation led into
annihilation conquest which led into
this great big huge expansion
of all the space-faring operas that
marvel had going on so that's why you
saw stories like rise and fall the shia
empire
where vulcan who was the third summer's
brother in omega level mutant left earth
and took over the shia
empire then you had the war of kings
realm of kings different things like
that but al ewing in a lot of ways seems
to be the guy that marvel turns to for
writing things that have to do with
space but what i also want to do here is
offer a bit of exposition in terms of
sword so sword is this organization that
was created by joss whedon back in
astonishing x-men really joss whedon and
john cassaday back with astonishing
x-men and the return of colossus but the
whole purpose behind this is that if
shield monitors threats on earth then
sword monitors threats to space
and so it basically stands for the
sentient world observation and response
directorate and though the whole purpose
is to just monitor threats that are out
there
that are potential threats to earth but
also stand as a kind of
kind of ambassador right so if there
were a great big huge coming together of
all the different alien races that exist
out there in marvel comics then abigail
brand would represent the solar system
right so you'd have like a
representative for the shiar and a
representative for the cree and the
representative for the scrolls or really
the korean scrolls now because
they've joined forces but all the
different alien races that are out there
and then abigail brand would represent
humanity in the sol system right in the
milky way galaxy um the idea behind
sword is that for a long time it was i
mean it was cool it had some
okay moments here and there but during
the incursions right during jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers and
in the aftermath of that
that sword was effectively rebranded
into what became the alpha flight
directorate or alpha fight protocol
program or whatever you want to call it
with carol danvers winning the show this
was an attempt by marvel to elevate the
popularity of carol danvers it didn't
really work
the story just really wasn't that great
and it just really wasn't written all
that well
and so that kind of lasted until the
empire event that we recently saw
conclude that we didn't finish because
it sucked
but what you ended up getting is this
segment whereby abigail brandt basically
quit the alpha flight program and the
reason why is because alpha flight was a
reactionary
organization they would wait till a
threat got there and then they would
react that in the fact that the
superheroes would never give any
information to the alpha flight program
because sword success came in the fact
that sword could tap into
all the information available to shield
and like the nsa and the fbi and the cia
and even the various other superhero
groups that would all funnel information
to sword to basically say hey look uh
like i summon galactus he's gonna be
stopping by right so he's not gonna be a
threat just fyi
don't shoot him with your big lasers
otherwise he'll kill assault like that
was kind of what like the fantastic four
would do or something along those lines
um and so because of that what we
basically have here is we don't really
know the current state of the alpha
flight program
it seems to still exist i wouldn't be
surprised if marvel just kind of quietly
phases it out like it's just never
really seen or heard from again i mean
we have it referenced here right so it
seems to exist only in so far as abigail
brand
quit but if the alpha flight program
still exists then sword has become an
extension of the mutant population
because abigail brand is a mutant that
has the ability to speak and understand
any language similar to cipher but it's
kind of like an alien language just not
every language in existence ever then
what this basically means is that sword
operates on behalf of coccoa and that's
why this opens up with magneto showing
up here
because sword now operating as an
extension of gracoa kind of falls under
the purview of krakowa and that's why
abigail brand being here she's being
returned as the leader of sword right
because she was originally the leader
when the group was first introduced by
joss whedon and she's
it was really kind of a return to
familiarity right she's right back where
she belongs more or less now for for
cable's part in the aftermath of the ten
of swords event he's actually been
elevated to the chief of security for
sword but the funny thing about this is
that
a lot of people and even with magneto a
lot of people don't really fully grasp
the power of magneto and it's one of
these things where whenever you see him
use his abilities you don't usually see
him do it on like a broad scale
right you don't really see him do like
some crazy super ridiculous thing it's
usually something like small or nuanced
or maybe some kind of interesting set of
circumstances but cable's mind is
totally blown
when while he's talking to magneto and
magneto is having this conversation and
talking about the whole basis behind
like the the sword peak is what it's
called kind of the base of operations
for sword it's called the peak wall is
called that you know
while they're we're having this
discussion and all that kind of stuff
magneto basically takes this 10
000 ton space station and changes it and
like moves it and puts it in a place
more in line with where
koha believes it should be he's just
doing it as an arbitrary thing like he's
literally doing multiple things
at the same time right so like where you
may find yourself doing something where
like you aimlessly play with something
in your hands right or you might tap a
pencil while you talk
imagine instead of tapping that pencil
having a conversation and then thinking
about a few things at the same time
you're moving a 10
000 ton space station across space
that's basically magneto now we have
seen him do crazy things like that right
like we've seen him pull like a bullet
from shia space right just yank it
towards earth or something along those
lines i think kitty pry was inside i
don't remember off top of my head we've
seen some crazy demonstrations of his
power and this is yet another one right
it's just been a while since we've seen
that but that's the thing like magneto's
power is extreme right it's it's crazy
how powerful he is and that's why i've
always advocated for the idea that while
i don't know if it's explicitly been
stated i don't remember if jonathan
hickman
modified this when he listed the new
omega level mutants in marvel comics but
magneto if he's not listed already
needs to be one right he's just that
damn powerful now from there magneto
basically gets a tour of where things
stand
with the with the sword space station
itself and we actually end up picking up
with a guy by the name of
takeshi matsuya right takeshi matsuya
this guy is old school right so he
originally appeared back in the old
exterminator comics but um really the
exterminators uh in 1988 and he's been
around for a long long time
i think his biggest claim to fame really
came when he served on generation x
so like emma frost's own x-men team back
in the day uh where emma frost started
out as a villain and she had her
hellions team
eventually the hellions were destroyed
and she ended up allying herself with
charles xavier and then led generation x
as her own personal x-men team like her
own personal new mutants more or less
takeshi is one of these guys where he
can basically
kind of control and really manipulate
things that are part of a
machine but the way that marvel explains
this is not just in technological
fashion right so it's not like he's a
tony stark type character that's really
his mutant power
he basically anything that works as part
of a greater cohesive unit
is considered to be part of a machine
right so if you had like
six mutants all of whose powers
complemented themselves then takeshi
could basically use that uses mutant
powers and find the most optimal way for
those mutant powers to work in unison
that's kind of how this whole thing how
this whole thing works so biotechnology
uh human technology any form of
technology he can effectively manipulate
so his powers are pretty extreme
because it goes beyond just like you
know i can understand how this robot
works and i can reverse engineer
iron man's armor and it moves way beyond
that right so
if you put him i would wager that if you
put him in charge of the avengers or
even just the x-men right if like the
x-men had to go to war
they would probably end up hitting up
takeshi and saying here's our roster how
would these mutant powers best work
together he's like well i mean because
you guys are working as kind of a
well-oiled machine so to speak
then this guy should do this and she
should do that and they should do this
and like these four people should fight
together
and those six people should fight
together and that kind of a thing now we
don't know the full depths of it the
full brunt of it marvel never really
bothered to explain the full depths of
what takeshi was capable of um
we will probably end up seeing that over
time but again he's kind of the guy
that's sort of helping to keep
the space station together he kind of
works as the control center so like the
brain
of the space station more or less but we
kind of get this continued bit of a
of an explanation right this continue
bit of a tour with everything going on
and that's when abigail brand really
kind of hits on
the big reason why she left alpha flight
and the big explanation given here is is
really kind of what we've already
reiterated that with alpha flight they
never really had the resources to do
what they wanted to do right that alpha
flight was a publicly available
government sanctioned superhero or
really a
i guess a space station kind of program
but they never really have the right
resources
back in the day shield had a blank
paycheck they had whatever they needed
to do
to achieve anything at any point in time
it's what made the old school nick fury
such a dangerous sky and see it could
happen into any database he had all the
money in the world nobody would ever
really say no to him uh and so because
of that they could achieve virtually
anything
sword had that when abigail brand was
initially running it when it first
popped up but when it became awful
flight then suddenly there were just
massive limitations on it and it
couldn't really fulfill its charter and
so once she's retaken over everything
she kind of came to this realization
that the universe is in a lot of ways
facing some pretty dire threats
she doesn't go as far as to say it
directly but basically null is heading
towards earth so we know that like sword
number one takes place before the events
of king and black there's like various
you know alien races out there that are
warring against each other that could
destabilize galactic peace
so while sword isn't necessarily the you
know universe's police force the purpose
of sword is to monitor threats out there
and to try to bring those threats to an
end if for no
other reason than to keep earth
protected right so like what we saw with
the
original pre-scroll war now the cree and
the scroll went to war against one
another and while they were races that
had been warning for millions of years
and had virtually nothing to do with
earth outside of the cree
creating inhumans on earth that when the
conflict came close enough to earth that
it actually threatened the earth itself
and so the purpose of of sword is to say
look yes they're warring empires that
are out there they'll probably never
come here
but it's entirely possible that they
could and because they could we need to
get involved in order to kind of bring
things to an
end so they're indirectly kind of
responsible in that way the next person
that we actually end up seeing here is a
person by the name of
frenzy and frenzy if i remember
correctly frenzy has
indestructible skin and super strength
but she is
a character that's really really really
really old school she's been around for
a very long time kind of a fun fact she
was actually working for apocalypse when
he first showed up in marvel comics in
the old x factor stories under walter
and louise simonson so she goes way back
right but frenzy
is a powerhouse right she's kind of the
muscle of the team right she's
you know the muscle of the of the six as
they call them that's what we kind of
get right each of these individuals here
offers something unique to the to the
the peak in such a way to where they can
be utilized or it can utilize itself at
its full capacity and all that whole
structure and formation
really seems to be done by way of the
efforts of takeshi right kind of working
together and saying look
these are the other five people that i
need to do these particular things
that can you know basically help this
thing operate in this peak capacity now
what the what what sword actually does
is not really just monitoring space they
have a much bigger charter going on and
we'll find out what that is
here in a second because what you end up
getting is this this kind of group sort
of coming together
you know in a mission effectively
getting ready to take off right a
mission getting ready to happen and
everybody
you know traveling to what's called the
uh the launch pad or the jump suite
where they basically teleport but but we
actually get two familiar faces here
anybody any of you guys who have been
reading marvel comics for i would say
the better part of 20 some odd years
you're gonna see a couple faces here
that are old school that you probably
recall the first one is peeper and i
didn't initially realize that people
would come back it wasn't until i was in
the discord
uh talking to you guys for the weekly q
a that i do every friday at 6 pm eastern
time
shameless plug uh but i was i was in the
q a session talking to you guys you know
answering your questions
and one of you guys asked me about sword
and you said that peeper came back so
peeper is one of the
old school i mean like og double og
brotherhood of evil mutant skies i think
he was part of the original brotherhood
of evil mutants with magneto if not the
original then the second iteration uh
but he's super old school they've been
around for a very very long time and
they've actually they've been friends
for a very long time now the fact that
people's back
of course magneto greets him as an old
friend he's like dude i had no idea that
you were on this we need to get back
together man like we need to hang out
we'll grab a beer and like
we'll chitchat and talk about all kinds
of stuff but the funny thing is that
fabian cortez
is left out of all of that now fabian
cortez was part of the acolytes right
back in the 1990s when you got x-men
volume 2 and the kind of relaunch under
chris claremont jim lee and then
eventually scott lodell and a few other
people once jim lee and chris claremont
left uh but the acolytes were like these
people who worshipped magneto right like
they basically did almost
every every single bidding that he could
possibly ask for fabian cortez had the
ability to augment the powers of other
people
um but he was by no means like a major
player the funny thing about that if i
remember correctly because sometimes i
get the tv show and the comics
uh switched but i believe fabian cortez
tried to topple magneto but whatever it
is magneto doesn't really remember his
name he's like i remember the ponytail
but the name escapes me so
fabian cortez was never really that
important to him in the first place and
so it leaves a little bit of room for
jealousy i doubt we'll actually see that
but
at that point the mission begins to
commence and these guys are addressing
these wild looking spacesuits because
they're not traveling out into space
they're actually breaking the
dimensional barrier and they're
traveling to three different locations
now these three different locations here
are represented by what's called the far
shore the land of couldn't be shouldn't
be
and the white hot room now the white hot
room a lot of you guys already know
we'll talk about that here in a minute
the far
shore in the land of couldn't be
shouldn't be those are the those are the
the ones a lot of people probably don't
really know much about right and it
stands to reason because they're very
new concepts and when i say very new
like they've been introduced
in the last four or five years and so
nobody's really done anything with them
usually when it comes to like abstract
ideas like that
they have to be around for something
like 20 years right in order to actually
get a general consensus of what they are
because a boatload of different writers
and artists interpret them in different
ways so
the far shore is a concept uh that was
explained to us and really given to us
during the old ultimate line of comics
by al ewing so like the ultimates with
adam beshear and black panther and
spectrum and all those characters as
part of all new all different marvel
um but we never really got a definitive
explanation in terms of what it really
is
the closest explanation that we get
comes at the end of the ultimate story
when we're basically told
that if you look at every universe that
exists out there every universe has its
own version of like eternity or
infinity or something like that and
every version of the multiverse has its
own version of the multiverse eternity
the multiverse
annual infinity and so every time a
universe dies
and is reborn the version of eternity
that existed when that universe died
basically ceased to exist and when the
universe is reborn a new version of
eternity
is borne in to that new universe and so
the question becomes
if that version of eternity that died
when the when the universe died
is gone then where does he go does he
simply cease to exist
and for for the most part i think it's
just an easier explanation to say that
right that version of eternity ceases to
exist and like a new one takes its place
but the answer that was given to us by
al ewing is
they go to the far shore so like when
the multiverse died during the events of
secret wars and was reborn again
uh that we basically ended up getting
like all those versions and all those
versions of the cosmic entities so like
eternity infinity master order lord
chaos the in-betweener then all those
cosmic entities basically died and when
the multiverse was recreated by reed
richards that for the most part they
were brought back the way they were
before so nothing really changed but if
you look at the multiverse the way it
died when
like gallon moved into the new new
multiverse and became galactus right
that transitionary period
that that version of eternity from the
previous multiverse that version of
infinity all those different cosmic
entities from
all those different universes that were
all wiped out when that multiverse
collapsed they all went to the far shore
now what they do when they're there we
don't know maybe they sit around all day
and watch golden girls maybe they play
ping pong who knows maybe they watch my
videos i have no other clue
we really don't know what it is that
they do uh we're never really given an
answer right it's just kind of it's
basically a a place where they go when
they quote unquote
pass on right when they basically die
and go on to whatever awaits them next
and and so from there you go into what's
called the land of couldn't be shouldn't
be
now the land of couldn't be shouldn't be
it's basically a a kind of dimension
or space that represents every
conceivable possibility that has not
come to fruition yet
right so let's make this tangible
because i know this is kind of wild
let's say that you have a plate of of
like cookies sitting next to you you
have a chocolate chip cookie you have a
sugar cookie and you have an oatmeal
raisin cookie i don't know why anybody
would eat that
now though there's a possibility all
those possibilities exist
right there's a possibility that you
could eat the chocolate chip cookie
there's a possibility you could eat the
sugar cookie
and there's a possibility you can eat
the oatmeal raisin cookie but until you
do
those are only possibilities but they're
only options that exist out there
there's they haven't come to fruition
yet and so that's what that's what that
whole kind of dimensional place answers
right if these ideas if these
possibilities exist then what do those
possibilities come from now the reality
is that this is adding a level of
complexity to something that doesn't
need that level of complexity we don't
need a dimension to represent
all the possibilities that could exist
in marvel comics right we can just call
that imagination and be done with it
right that's all it is
that's that's all it really needs to be
but marvel likes to assign
uh dimensional spaces and cosmic
entities to different ideologies
for whatever reason only makes sense to
themselves and so the the land of
couldn't be shouldn't be
represents those three cookies sitting
on those plates now let's say for
example that you decide to eat that
chocolate chip cookie
then that becomes a reality right you
now live in a universe where you ate
that chocolate chip cookie
there is an alternate reality out there
where you ate the oatmeal raisin cookie
and there's an
alternate reality where you ate the the
sugar cookie right like there's there
are now alternate realities for those
because with that situation being there
the very fact that you chose to eat a
cookie means now you chose to eat all
the other cookies or you chose to eat
none of them i know it's really weird
and it's really wild and meta-textual
and that's why i say not everything that
can exist
needs to exist not every idea that
somebody comes up with
needs to actually be put in comic books
so if you find yourself a little
confused just kind of sit on that for a
little while and just kind of ponder it
and it'll eventually make sense to you
after a while but from there they
finally managed to make their way into
the white hot room right and access
something called
the mysterium tremendous don't know what
that is where it's the first time that
we saw it
this stuff's kind of cool it seems a
little unnecessary and that's why i say
like it's an awesome concept
but it's really kind of running like
just throwing in too much wild stuff too
fast uh but again it could all make
sense by the time we get to the next
issue whatever this
is though this basically kind of seems
to be a cosmic uh like
an elemental cosmic heart right the
heart of the white hot room now the
white hot room those of you guys who
don't know what this is
this is basically where you have the
phoenix force in its full totality right
the full power of the phoenix force now
just because a person
is possessed by the phoenix force does
not mean they can use the phoenix force
to its full potential that in order for
that to happen there has to be an almost
kind of
alignment between the genetic potential
of the person who is a host for the
phoenix force and the phoenix force
itself right so that's why like jean
grey
is the quote unquote perfect host for
the phoenix someone like i think uh i
think emma frost achieved it for a time
i believe rachel summers has
um and i think i know quentin choir did
in an alternate universe um but
basically a person who
is who's able to possess the totality of
the phoenix powers
is what's called the white phoenix of
the crown right that's basically what
they are a person who can achieve
and use the phoenix's abilities to their
full totality a person who achieves that
level
occupies and exists inside the white hot
room but we never really got a full-on
explanation beyond that right that's old
chris claremont stuff that was kind of
revisited by grant morrison during his
run on x-men with here comes tomorrow
but beyond that we don't really have a
full-on explanation there in terms of
like
what all is inside the white hot room
we're told that it's like kind of
surrounded by like a latticework
you know and it's like a place of pure
energy but what they seem to have done
here
is taken the heart of the white hot room
right this this
object that can kind of maintain these
sort of elemental capacities now
what that means and what it does i have
no idea i don't know if attaining this
makes them all god
i don't know if it just allows them to
tap into a level of power
maybe it makes them super smart we don't
really know it's one of these things
where just because there's an artifact
that holds a ceremonial role
does not mean that artifact is going to
grant a person absolute power
indicative of that role right so this
artifact resides in the white hot room
the only people who can access the white
hot room
are people who are able to use the
phoenix force at 100 of its power
ergo anybody who has this artifact can
you know possesses the full totality of
the phoenix's powers we don't know that
we're assuming that but we don't
actually have an answer for that the
result is we're just going to kind of
have to wait and see
what all this means but once they attain
this artifact and they bring it back
the only thing that we're really told is
like this is what comes next
right like this is basically what what
comes after all this what that means i
have no idea right it's a great
huge mystery i'm digging it i like it i
think it's cool and i'm excited to see
what comes of it uh al ewing almost
never disappoints as a writer i don't
think i've ever read a bad story that al
ewing wrote so i'm excited to see you
know where this goes but
it is a little wild it is a little kooky
but it leaves room for some pretty crazy
events especially because we're going
cosmic in this right so probably a lot
of involvement involving cosmic entities
different things like that so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob court
if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you